hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
another high-definition video and today
we're going to be taking a look at while
actually unboxing for our videos on the
mkbhd youtube channel the Canon EOS
Rebel t2i and the 18 to 55 millimeter is
lens kit from Canon I saw the price of
this what this was available for at my
favorite online retailer and I was
really really impressed could it not say
no it was a ridiculously good price so
um I'm pretty much getting this as my
intro to DSLRs in preparation for the
Canon t3i in February and I guess thumbs
up if you want to see this camera given
away because I really this will be
replacing this camera in my
point-and-shoot so yeah I mean I've got
really good quality out of this camera
the Sanyo Zack DC g10 but without any
further ado I mean the rebel box is my
favorite clothes of course red and black
tells you a little bit about system
requirements for editing but without you
further ado let's take a look inside so
pretty excited for this here is the
shipping information not really all that
important actually that's a warranty by
the way that's a warranty here's your
digital soft force instruction manual
and the software really good software
whether you control your camera with
your computer and here's the readers
guide or manuals that'll be reading
through of course to get a better idea
of using camera and get to the good
stuff so hardware so here's a lens strap
the Canon red black signature lens strap
I suppose we have here is a power cable
for the charger which is here so there's
a wall adapter and here is the battery
charger itself so you can see those LEDs
for charging in full so that's pretty
good you also have the Canon battery
here and this looks like a I mean it
will take a still apart off I'll get in
show you is pretty I've heard good
things about this camera's battery life
stuff I have no complaints but anyway
we're get into this inside put this to
the side
let's have your USB cable to connected
to your computer to import photos or to
charge it if you really want to and your
component cable which I'll be using to
monitor on my monitor so here is the
camera itself given the lens later
here's the body oh man it feels really
solid go ahead and move this off to the
side and here is the Canon t2i
looks really really good solid solid
feel I got to say the lens I will
definitely do a whole a full review of
this and the 18 to 55 milliliter lens
the 50 milliliter prime lens which I've
been recommended by a lot of you guys
and this is the of course the body
itself over on the left hand side a big
feature the t2i is a HDMI out and
microphone input which is really helpful
the battery of course will go on the
bottom right here you have your tripod
which is lined up with the center of the
lens 3.0 inch LCD screen just overall
really really nice looking camera so
we'll be getting back to you guys with a
review of this but you can expect this
to be the last of the Sanyo FTC g10
videos didn't really need this knife
here on the YouTube channel so until
next time there's been mkbhd within
boxing of the Canon t2i and I'll talk to
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching please